Nicolas Sarkozy a raison il faut
absolument faire parler de soi
alors un peu plus rien dire on va faire
le test ultime pour savoir si on peut
vraiment on peut rien dire on va faire
une interview fin de phrase
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fini mes phrases d'accord
je dis pas qu'il y a que des [__] des
drogués à la télé je dis que
non il y a des gens il y a des gens
différents
Pascal Sevran
par exemple
ce qui est bien quand tu es [__] c'est
que tu as pas besoin de divorcer encore
donc ça va peut-être venir
je rêve d'une France nettoyée de
des journalistes qui me posent des
questions de con mais vraiment c'est ça
et des invités qui viennent à la télé ah
Nicolas Sarkozy a raison il faut
absolument faire parler de soi
il ne faut pas jeter la pierre au
pédophile car tu pourrais blesser
l'enfant qui porte dans les bras
tu vois Thierry un handicapé c'est
toujours c'est un mec qui a pas de
chance parce qu'au moment où il y a
plein de places pour les handicapés de
stationnement en interdit la voiture en
ville
je suis pour la Parisienne femme bien
sûr sauf si sauf si Laurent Baffie
remplacé par Christine Boutin
la phrase qu'il ne faut surtout pas dire
en ce moment c'est
on peut pas plaire à tout le monde
j'aime bien voir des flics dans la rue
parce que ils sont pas dans le bistrot
ils sont pas
le vrai problème avec les Juifs
aujourd'hui c'est
il y a pas de problème
on dit que les Arabes sont voleurs c'est
faux
il y a des problèmes
tous les musulmans ne sont pas des
terroristes mais non mais les petites
musulmanes c'est les petites bombes
[Applaudissements]
la qualité qu'on pourra jamais enlever à
l'islamiste c'est
c'est d'Emmer des bouches
[Applaudissements]
ce qui m'énerve chez les catholiques
c'est
qu'ils Élise des papes un peu trop un
peu trop black et surtout trop jeune
[Rires]
sont des cons mais tout le monde en
parle voilà exactement
[Applaudissements]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu